the jogan experience I was thinking
because um like you can see so much
Carnage online now like in my algorithm
I guess I don't know enough comedians
sent me videos of people getting
murdered and [__] yeah my algorithm is
terrible it's just like butts and like
car accidents and how the Disney castles
are made of dicks like
that's he that from
tripol did you know that Tripoli has 12
podcasts yeah at least
I'm GNA give birth oh no and so yeah so
Triple E sends me all the stuff but yeah
the I mean the Disney Castle is being
made of dicks it is it is a compelling
case but I think it was probably more
that they didn't pay their animators and
the animators were like [__] you guys
we're just going to make the you know
I'm not totally aware of that one I
think I don't remember it let's disne
Castle's made a dicks let's go about to
get well there's a lot of wild stuff
from the old Disney stuff you go back in
the old old Disney like you guys bury
this brutal I know you might you might
want to take the obviously Jewish
person's nose down a little bit there
was one where uh there was a a it was
like a big bad wolf one and it used to
be a Jewish person and then they
switched it to a wolf later M like what
and it's like cheap it like won't pay
the price for the baguette for the
Little Red Riding Hood you're like what
yeah but like there's there's the I
think it's the little mermaid the spears
looking like dicks the I think they
probably just didn't pay their animators
and the animators were like all right
we're just going to make everything look
like a dick but some people do see dicks
and everything though there's that it is
kind of a war shock test that's a thing
yeah
maybe maybe I'm one of those people uh
then there's also Minnie Mickey and
Minnie like one of her bows it does kind
of look like a dick going right for her
mouth I mean it feels like a disgruntled
employee what the video you posted got
taken down I was just going to play that
one
post removed which one was that one
about this on this topic on the she has
a video that I was just going to like
use that as an example but it's been
take they take all my stuff down now I
here's some interesting uh stuff I just
found though marshmallow Cannon what but
hold on I mean it'll it should show like
no yeah well oh
what okay that's 100% a dick squirting
marshmallows on a little M there's ited
all over this mouse it's that it's like
okay that's a dick that's 100% a dick
it's like look at the balls at the
bottom of it that's not a coincidence I
didn't even notice the balls that is not
a coincidence that's 100% a dick look up
uh the mini and Mickey Mouse that one is
the one that really kind of put me over
the edge yeah that's someone being
sneaky and putting in like a little
Easter egg yeah yeah they didn't get
paid over time that's a dick yeah and
now the Disney employees are trying or
the animators are trying to unionize I'd
be shocked if they succeed they're
probably just going to have ai do it you
could also just go to images the thing
is AI is so good now like these
animators are on Shaky Ground yes that's
correct um what happened with the actor
strike did they settle that is that over
yeah they settled it uh oh do Minnie and
Mickey dicks Minnie and Mickey dicks
dicks oh it's right there go to the one
two three four like six over on the top
yeah one more over sorry that one yeah
oh Jesus Christ that's her dress what
the [__] I know okay it's a little while
come
on I mean maybe that's insane and he's
got his hand on her dick she's got a
giant heart on that is 100% a hard on
that doesn't even make sense as a dress
straight into his mouth I just try to
imagine that as a dress it doesn't even
make sense like where's her arm oh it's
around his neck who cares where it
doesn't make sense I know it it's hard
right arm a hard one to oh they're both
around there she's hugging him and
that's her shoulder supposedly okay
kindee kind of it's a tough one that's a
dick it's way more of a dick than it is
her arm around his shoulder uhhuh you
know if it's one of two things that
looks so much like it and his hands on
it like he's stroking it and also the
little lines I don't know do she always
have a puffy shoulder shirt on like that
is that consistent not like that and
then it's also like the little Ridge on
the top doesn't feel necessary it's a
dick that's definitely a dick Shadow oh
no it's that's 100% a dick oh no yeah
I'm going to get a dart in my neck any
minute Disney's going to guess they're
already in trouble they [__] up they
went too far you were telling us about
the South Park thing oh my god dude
Jamie have you seen the new South Park I
definitely saw clips of it so funny
first of all Cartman it has been
replaced by by a black Trans
woman in the in like the ulterior
universe or whatever and the whole thing
well really incisive commentary
obviously they always do such a good job
with this um it's the panda verse
hilarious it's such a great name all the
handyman the handyman are the richest
people because no men know how to do
anything anymore because they went to
college so it's all about how college
has made us stupid and we need handymen
to do everything now because we using
Siri and whatever so there's the the
handyman bought Instagram and now is
like going to space cuz he's just a
billionaire and then Cartman is uh C is
it Katherine Kennedy who runs Disney but
Rand Lucas film and whatever and her
whole thing is just make it make it a
girl and make her gay make it a girl and
make her
gay for every movie they're bitching and
she she gets like served food at a
restaurant and she's like I told you to
make it a girl make it
G it's hilarious it's so well done yeah
how did that H how did they people that
are that goofy get in control of media
like that I think that like there's a
really I think we're going to look back
at this time and go like remember when
we thought 300 comments on Twitter
represented everyone right remember when
we had that confirmation but we got
scared of a bunch of tweets half of
which might just be Bots or truly crazy
people